[Applause]
nfts have to be sold at this current
time
in a cryptocurrency called ethereum yes
right
yes ethereum is a crypto just like
bitcoin just like anyone that has value
and that value can increase or decrease
right how do you increase the value
of a currency right by flowing
liquidity remember the velocity of money
conversation we have
by flowing liquidity into that currency
okay right so the more people that are
interested in buying ethereum the more
valuable ethereum is going to be go go
go so the more people who own ethereum
the more interest they have in pumping
up nfts because you nft transactions
haven't
the other way around right in order to
buy nfts
yeah you need to buy ethereum first
right yeah so if it looks like
everybody who buys nfts becomes a
millionaire yeah well we got to get into
the nft game
right and if you're a collector you got
to get into an nft game
so now as a collector you buy your
ethereum first yeah
and then you buy the nft the the nfc
almost functions as a marketing tool for
the crypto itself
i bought ethereum only because i was
like
ooh this nft thing is kind of popping i
think it could spike
yeah so i'm not the only one that did
that
yeah well that wasn't some super smart
investment move i bet a bunch of people
were like oh this nft thing is going to
be a craze for a little bit
let me buy some crypto and nft not even
to buy nfts
but because so many people are going to
be buying ethereum right
right this is where we get potentially
nefarious
and we go back to the twitter cnn
argument
what if you're let's say the
winklevosses right
yeah and you have tens of billions maybe
hundreds of billions of dollars
invested in cryptocurrencies not just
bitcoin but ethereum
yeah would it be worth it to you
to throw a hundred million dollars at
this nft market to inflate it
you would only need to make 101 million
dollars
in the value of ethereum going up
due to these nfts in order for you to be
profitable right
could this nft market be completely
inflated
yeah right by people who are pot
committed
to the crypto ethereum yeah if i'm an
ethereum
holder if i own the company itself yeah
like i'm vitalik buterin or whatever the
[ __ ] i'm going yo do we have a marketing
budget
give me 200 million dollars buy a bunch
of [ __ ] [ __ ] art that's not worth
nothing
because there's no exclusionary value to
it
the whole reason you buy something is
because it is exclusive to you
and the fact that you could jpeg any of
these things now is no longer exclusive
right right if if i have a marketing
budget of 200 million dollars i'm
throwing it at these nft things i'm
building up that beeple [ __ ]
i'm doing bids that are real yeah but
they're also not
real yeah you buy starting nft yeah i
start an nft
i'll buy yours for a thousand ethereum
you buy mine for a thousand ethereum
now you're worth a thousand ethereum in
your art and i am but we're equal in
money
yeah there's no trade processing there's
nothing we just gave each other
people are looking on the outside like
yo they made a million dollars worth of
ethereum on these nfts we should get
into nfts and we just
handed money back and forth both
switched accounts so switching money
back and forth
no real reason to like you're not going
through any real middle man right
yeah i think that you can just trade the
ethereum directly maybe there's some
small processing fee or something
who knows but it's a great marketing
tool for a crypto
because you have to have that crypto in
order to access it yeah and it almost
makes it look like this is just
beginning this is the future and in
order to be part of the future
you got to own this currency right the
the only pushback i think somebody who's
all four nfts would give i think is that
because everything's on the blockchain
and you can see all the purchases that
are being made sure so you can see the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] if
like oh you're just buying that and then
he's buying it right back
so some people would be like nah but you
the fact that it's all
transparent then that can't happen but
my thing with it which is what i asked
uh pap
is like nobody's checking this [ __ ]
exactly
everybody said yes it's transparent you
can do it what what what's like do you
go to jail
how do i check the theory of blockchain
i don't know
you know how to change blockchain they
act like the ethereum blockchain's times
square you just go look at the
just look at it yeah it ain't no website
for that [ __ ] right how do i just
look at what's meant and also it's one
blockchain the ethereum blockchain do
you know how many
tens of thousands of transactions
probably happen on that it's like
finding a name at the vietnam memorial
you're just gonna be looking through
that [ __ ] forever till you finally come
across your
grandfather who fought in the war i
would assume it's more streamlined than
that but here's what one thing i will
say i agree with what you said and it's
all
completely possible maybe probable yeah
that doesn't make nfts not valuable
though
that doesn't mean it can't float the
entire market into the point where nfts
just become the way we invest in art
that's 100 true true the thing about art
and this was always my issue when it
came to nfts i'm not saying that it's
not possible
between had a great idea for for an nft
that i'll get to in a second but
the thing about art right is the fact
that it is exclusive to you
right like you own a piece of art that
is yours yeah it's
exclusionary value yeah you could own
this jpeg
but if anybody else can just copy the
jpeg and post it there it's not
exclusive to you the mona lisa is
exclusive to whoever owns that mona lisa
and has
offered to give it to the louvre for
whatever reason but they could also put
it in their bathroom
and it is exclusive and then the only
place that you could see it
is you and i think that we'll see
another version of the nft like we were
saying i believe in the blockchain
technology and i believe in
the verification of goods but
right now the idea of like a digital
asset being worth something because it's
more because it's verified when all of
us know that there's really no
difference
in this other thing right it's just
going to lessen
the value a little bit go maybe you've
maybe addressed this in that last point
tell me if you did i think it still has
value because of something you said
earlier which is we are so invested in
like the podcast we listen to
and whatever other digital media it's
all digital for the most part
everything we consume so digital art
doesn't seem like much of a stretch and
digital memorabilia from those people
that we're so invested in
if joe rogan nft his alex jones episode
and you got the fans of joe rogan and
the fans of alex jones
they're gonna want that [ __ ] emotionally
that's from these guys that i worship
i've invested tens of thousands of hours
in i'll pay 100
people are gonna pay for things like
people buy things on fortnight that
aren't real
all the time so people pay real money on
digital things there's no question
um and another point i just want to
bring up like when it came comes to like
why would you throw 200 million dollars
at a cryptocurrency like what would be
the advantage of that
well if you got into ethereum when it
was worth one penny
and now it's worth 1700 and you have a
million shares
you made way more than whatever so you
have all this money that's not even
really real
it's just out of nowhere yeah right like
like the people that got into crypto
right now are just
millionaires multi-millionaires
billionaires so they have all this money
that's in crypto
that they know that they didn't really
earn so they're willing to throw it
around a little bit
because they they literally the cost of
it was [ __ ] pennies you know can i
push back a little bit yeah go
couldn't the s p 500 who has more money
than any of these crypto guys do the
same thing with the stock market
stock market's been up throughout the
pandemic for the most part they did
so that's that's what the stimulus is
how do you think the stock market is
going up because they're inflating the
[ __ ] out of it so isn't it the same
thing as
it's just it's i it's happening no
matter where you put your money yeah i
guess what i'm saying is it's not real
yeah you're peeing on yourself and
eventually you run out of pee yeah and
then somebody gotta deal with them wet
pants
yeah and usually it's not the rich
[ __ ] they gotta deal with the
wet pants
usually support [ __ ] they gotta
deal with it and they support
[ __ ] who get in at the end like
i'm gonna make some money off this nft
arc
and then once the house of cards falls
it's all a house of cards like every
economy is a house of cards yes but
usually the house of cards falls on the
poor people who get in last
because they're like oh [ __ ] i can make
money on this like we're getting in last
like when when we're out here talking
these [ __ ] on boats they
already made millions on it
yeah like we're at the end of this [ __ ]
you know what i mean
yeah we're not at the end though we're
like in the middle where
there's there's a big portion of the
society
you're sleeping on how many people if
bitcoin is the economy which economy do
you believe in more
if bitcoin becomes the economy that wins
yeah a lot of my [ __ ]
have gotten in way too late put it this
way like if you want to look at um
where the beginning and the end is you
you look uh
at what the peak value
of the currency is going to be right
and uh right now in order for us to
double our money on bitcoin that we just
bought
bitcoin has to go to 120 000 correct
correct
the people that got in early oh they're
early they got in when it was pennies
right yeah
so like if you look at the lifeline of
bitcoin from
one penny to 120 000 we're at the
very very end correct you know now if it
gets you
we're definitely like even for bitcoin
to go to a million
yeah we're still in the last 10 of the
lifeline of bitcoin
compared to the person who got it a
penny and now it says 60 000.
yeah no there's i think you what i'm
saying is that percentage of people that
are gonna get in one is that like 150
is way higher than you realize so
relative to the pennies guys we are
[ __ ] poppers
but we're still getting in at a decent
time what i'm explaining is
is not the amount of people that get in
yeah i'm talking about
the value the value correct right yeah
the reason i'm looking at the lifeline
in terms of value
not in terms of the velocity i guess is
just because of how much you can make
out of it yeah because we're having
discussion of like who's really made
money off this [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so
so these people like can you do the math
real quick uh first
bitcoin to go from 60 000 to a million
how many x that is
i think it's 16 so 16 times right
so if bitcoin goes from now to a million
let's say it goes to a million which
would be crazy
yeah that that's 16 times the money the
people that got into bitcoin
at a penny yeah have already made
what 60 000 times
100. what is that
60 million x yeah their money
no i know so in the lifeline 6000x
they've already made what like if you
went if you got in at a penny yeah and
it got to
60 000. oh actually no excuse me no i
think you're right yeah
60 million that's fine 60 million x so
so
we can make 16 times our money if it
does the greatest thing that will ever
happen to bitcoin we make 16 times the
money
they made 60 million times
their money yeah they're [ __ ] on us
so that when i say
we got in at the end this is still a
good time to get in because more
investors will be in
yes i'm not sure on that yeah but in
terms of
who's really made money on this yeah
yeah
other currencies are almost more
exciting you know what was cool about
this though
about what's cool about bitcoin is
normally the people who
control everything are the same people
that have been controlling everything
for hundreds maybe thousands of years
yeah this crypto [ __ ] as far as i know i
know a ton of people who got rich as
[ __ ]
early as [ __ ] who have no association
with those guys and now they got real
money
my homie roy who has bitcoin will not
tell me how much he has
that's how i know he's richer than
anyone i know so here's my
go out you had a question then i'll say
something still even those people who
got in super early who are probably just
looking at their account and it's like
some
stock like crazy number it's still just
a digital number that they can't do
anything with well they could sell it
into dollars
but they haven't been because they just
want to keep seeing it rise rise
so it's like at the end of the day yes
you have a lot of money but until people
start pulling that [ __ ] out
it's worthless and then what happens
when they pull it out then it pops and
then everybody
who wasn't smart to pull it out early
loses their money
sure so it's like it this is a balloon
that's going to pop one day eventually
one of these [ __ ] who are
sitting on billions is gonna be like
ah i wanna trade it in for cash and
that's just gonna
[ __ ] up the whole system i don't know i
can't make the full connection but i
know if it becomes the currency of
choice and that's just what we go off of
when
when he said like i think there's a
point in which we stop even thinking of
bitcoin in terms of how many dollars
it's worth
and it's just how many bitcoin do you
have that's the future he foresees
whether that happens or not that's when
it becomes i don't think it's impossible
it just gets more stable i don't think
yeah it has to be more stable like
here's something that you gotta think
about
a currency needs to have some ability to
be
stable now bitcoin is the most stable of
all them but like
let's say you're getting paid weekly in
bitcoin yeah
and you build your lifestyle around this
weekly salary
yeah you can't afford your salary to
take a
20 hike on a random friday correct
because your lifestyle
corrects built around a secure amount
when you get paid in dollars or british
pounds of these things there is still
that security
even though we all want to believe all
the dollars going down and all this
other stuff
there still is something to be said
about the fact that you can have a
[ __ ]
hundred dollar bill and you can go to a
nightclub you could pay for that
there is security there so we are maybe
who knows maybe it's five years away
maybe it's 25 years away
but we we do all recognize there is a a
future with this technology yeah we
don't know which currency
is going to be the currency i have a
hard time believing there's just going
to be like one global reserve currency
unless there's a
country that enforces it and then it's
just
the currency of that country oh the most
comforting thing to me is that if it's
true that the u.s is the second largest
holder of bitcoin oh if that came out
i'm all in
yeah because that's what came out i
really think that might be our only
chance against china
because if bitcoin wins and we have the
second most yeah i'm
ethereum yeah i'm making a deal with the
us government right now oh yeah
i'm going yo do you want to partner up
you know
let's we will give you half of our
holdings you become the biggest
shareholder [ __ ] become the 51 percent
shareholder then people probably
wouldn't invest because of the
the ho they have control of of what the
currency does and they could make more
and blah blah blah
not decentralized at 51 i digress point
is
there's it is a very interesting time i
think throughout history you have these
times where these people make millions
of dollars out of nowhere i'm sure this
happened at the gold rush or the copper
rush and
i'm sure there's tons of times
throughout history where people were
able
you know some average person was able to
get in on an investment and make tons of
money out of nowhere right
i think that's probably what the idea
the inception of america was on some
level yeah
um we might be existing in that right
now right who [ __ ] knows
but it's just a crazy time to be alive
yeah this is actually an interesting
point that from
from 2020 this article came out that
says the fbi or like government
intelligence agencies own
according to this article like the
fourth most amount
of bitcoin because they've come from
confiscating it from
the dark web drug bazaar and then silk
road bust and all that
all this stuff they have about 9.5
million bitcoin
and there's 21 million in existence uh
let me take that
uh actually i i can't say exactly that
seems high
but if that's the case possibly have
more yeah yeah if you have 9.5
okay it says that the website was
reaching 9.5 million bitcoin at some
point
and that they confiscated a chunk of it
okay but they got some millions then
and they have to get access to it they
might not have access to it and that's
assuming the us government and
and no other branch has been like just
buying bitcoin apparently bulgaria has
got to [ __ ] some
213 000 bitcoin yeah but they could keep
that little 230
[ __ ] yo honestly if i was a small
country
oh it's so worth the investment oh yeah
yeah are you [ __ ] kidding that is a
massive come up for them yeah yeah
that's what he was saying venezuela was
doing oh that's right they were mining
it like crazy
but i would just have government policy
take one percent of your gdp and then
just put that [ __ ] into crypto because
you never [ __ ] know
you could be this bitch-ass little
country just yeah mushed around left or
right or you could become a crypto
billionaire
country safe haven like have your
country operate off of crypto that's a
brilliant idea yeah
iceland get in on it you want to be
bitch-ass little countries your whole
life
and i think that's kind of his point
about why countries can't really they
won't ever stop crypto
because they'll eventually be like oh
there's a lot of money in this we should
just keep it for ourselves and start
trading or whatever
he said the the goal the selfish goal is
always going to win